do you have any feinman stories that you
haven't told before
that i haven't told before um
or how about this
you mentioned one time
perhaps more that feynman is
misapprehended as someone who has an
extreme understanding he does but he was
great at calculation and that
calculation allowed him to understand
and perceive apprehend what other
misunderstandings or false impressions
do people have about find me that you're
able to see from the inside
oh the one that that always drove him
crazy was um and you know you mentioned
at the beginning of uh
of this you know people
sort of uh
uh ad hominem attacks
that uh that i may get which i'm
blissfully unaware of for the most part
but but um the um
you know
uh
uh people one of the things that drove
feynman crazy was that people thought of
him as you know the quintessential nice
guy
you know would listen to anything etc
etc etc but in fact
like all of us
you know he got impatient he valued his
time etc etc etc and so when people
would kind of get close to him and he
would be like kind of snarky with them
and so on they would say oh my gosh you
know you're supposed to be this this
wonderfully nice you know positive
person and actually you're kind of
snarky that's terrible that's horrible
i'm i'm i'm you know that's that's very
horrifying so so actually one of the
things he always used to tell me is
don't don't appear to be too nice
because it's actually a worse life
than um uh uh than the other so to speak
i'm not sure that i've intentionally
taken that to heart but um it was one of
those things but i think
here's the thing that um
uh
i talked a lot to dick feynman about
quantum mechanics
and uh he would always say
you know we don't really understand
quantum mechanics you know we can
calculate this and that we don't really
understand it we don't have an intuitive
understanding what's going on it's a
shame he's not still around because i
would really have had a good time
telling him about the stuff we figured
out now and it's you know one of the
things i remember just these endless
conversations about why does
thermodynamics eta minus beta h quantum
mechanics is e to the iht why are they
both exponentials like that why is uh
and i think we now know the answer and
it's it's pretty neat and it's um i
think that um
uh
somehow
i mean another thing that we don't yet
know they'll be interesting to see how
it plays out you know one of the
fineman's most famous probably single
most famous invention was fimin diagrams
this way of calculating uh things in
quantum field theory um
and one of the features of feynman
diagrams is
the simple ones are pretty easy to
compute
but there's this whole series of finemen
diagrams for any particular thing and
they get more and more and more
complicated and they get unbelievably
more difficult to compute so for example
right now there's a big sort of flap
because the anomalous magnetic moment of
the muon which is computed using feynman
diagrams there's a disagreement
apparently between the experiment and
the theory that's sort of why is that
the case
well you know it could be that one of
the things that happens is these series
of diagrams we don't actually know that
the ones that we can't compute yet are
really as small as we think they are and
anyway one of the things that i think
may come out
is um we may have an actual method for
doing computations in quantum field
theory that avoids feminine diagrams and
and feynman always thought
that he thought said fireman diagrams
are a crazy idea he would always say and
um you know i i you know
i can't believe people think you know
that there's got to be a better way to
do this this is a crazy way to do it
there's got to be a better way to do it
maybe we'll have such a way i'm not sure
there's there's also hints of better
ways that involve the um
uh the whole ads cft
uh business which is pretty closely
related i think to correspondence
between physical and branchial space in
our models so it may end up being the
same idea in the end